President Trump is taking the first
steps toward tougher gun regulations one
week after the school shooting in
parkland Florida the president tweeted
last night we must now focus on
strengthening background checks which
could mean anything from legislation the
NRA supports to legislation it strongly
opposes the president also wants to ban
bump stocks and other devices that can
enable rapid fire shooting Margaret
Brennan is at the White House where the
president will sit down with students
parents and teachers today to talk about
keeping schools safe Margaret good
morning good morning well in the wake of
last week's massacre the White House is
showing a new openness to gun control
measures today the president will hold a
listening session not only with members
of the Parkland community but also those
impacted by past school shootings in
Columbine and Sandy Hook we have to do
more to protect our children the
president told the Justice Department to
take swift action we must actually make
a difference efforts to ban bump stocks
last year were stalled by the NRA and
Republican leaders we think the
regulatory fix is the smartest quickest
fix the NRA disapproved of Tuesday's
directive arguing that banning
semi-automatic firearms and accessories
has been shown time and again to not
prevent criminal activity and punishes
the law-abiding for the criminal acts of
others bump stocks were not used in last
week's attack but a shooter in Las Vegas
did use them in October to kill 58
people in the deadliest shooting in US
history president Trump's personal views
continue to evolve in his 2000 book the
America we deserve mr. Trump wrote I
generally oppose gun control but I
support the ban on assault weapons a
position he reversed while running for
office now in response to the outcry
from students and activists the White
House is signaling it may revisit the
ban on assault style rifles like the
ar-15 firearm used in the Florida attack
we haven't closed the door on any front
and may consider changing the age limit
for those purchasing military-style
weapons it's certainly something that's
on the table for us to discuss
is not clear how many of the parkland
student activists were invited here to
the White House yesterday one of the
more outspoken david hog said that he
had turned down an invitation to come
here in favor of a prior TV commitment
john he explained that the president had
also been invited to that TV town-hall
margaret thanks